en este año 2023 se han cumplido ya 20
años de la invasión de Irak y ya sé lo
que estaréis pasando prácticamente todos
Ay Dios mío qué mayor me estoy haciendo
Ya lo sé posiblemente estamos hablando
de la guerra que marcó la adolescencia
de muchos de los que estaréis viendo
Este vídeo sobre todo los que tengáis
entre 30 y 40 años seguro que muchos de
vosotros todavía tenéis en vuestra
cabeza imágenes que ya forman parte de
la historia imágenes tan famosas y tan
icónicas como esta y seguros seguro que
muchos de vosotros también recordáis las
grandes manifestaciones y protestas en
contra de la guerra y esto es algo muy
interesante porque esta guerra se
produjo prácticamente al mismo tiempo
que la guerra de Afganistán sin embargo
la intervención militar en Afganistán
tuvo mucha mejor prensa Por qué Pues
porque todo el mundo entendía que era
una respuesta adecuada a los atentados
del 11s sin embargo la guerra de Irak
fue muchísimo más polémica el llamado no
a la guerra fue el lema de una serie de
protestas multitudinarias en contra de
la decisión del gobierno de Estados
Unidos de invadir Irak especial
protagonismo tuvo el mundo del cine en
España es más seguro que si veis este
vídeo desde España recordaréis esa de
los Goya donde todos los actores
hicieron un acto de protesta contra el
gobierno de José María aznar conservador
que apoyaba esta guerra Pues bien
curiosamente nadie duda 20 años después
de que la guerra de Afganistán fue un
fracaso total un fracaso que terminado
con los talibanes de nuevo en el poder
después de una evacuación bastante
bochornosa en cambio en Irak todavía hoy
permanecen alrededor de 2500 soldados
estadounidenses es más todo indica que
no hay ninguna prisa para que se vayan
el Primer Ministro era aquí apoya la
presencia indefinida de tropas
estadounidenses vamos que a día de hoy
un soldado estadounidense no puede
entrar en Afganistán ni aunque quisiera
mientras que al mismo tiempo en Irak son
casi está bienvenidos bueno no del todo
pero ya me entendéis Así que la pregunta
es por qué se produjo la guerra de Irak
Hasta qué punto fue un fracaso Cómo es
el Irak actual Pues bien hoy vamos a
responder a todas estas preguntas pero
antes vamos a ver un poco de historia
[Música]
el malo de la película
hubo una época allá por los años 90 en
el que la unión soviética daba ya menos
miedo que expediente x y la amenaza
china parecía más bien el nombre de una
prueba de humor amarillo Así que durante
muchos años Sadam hussein fue el malo de
la película El icono de la maldad
Incluso en South Park era más malo que
el propio demonio era tan malo que ya en
la guerra que enfrentó a Irak con Irán
en los años 80 la Casa Blanca terminó
por apoyar al régimen de los ayatolas
quizás para garantizar que nadie ganara
y las dos partes perdieran pero lo
cierto Es que apoyaron a Irán antes que
Irak
A mediados de los 80 estalló el
escandaló Irán contra la administración
del presidente Ronald Reagan estaba
vendiendo secreto armas a Irán un país
sobre el que pesaba un embargo
armamentístico decretado por los propios
Estados Unidos con el dinero obtenido la
Casa Blanca financiaba la contra un
grupo armado que luchaba para derrocar
al gobierno nicaragüense surgido de la
Revolución sandinista ambas operaciones
la venta de armas e Irán y la
financiación de las contras estaban
prohibidas por el senado estadounidense
[Música]
Lo cierto es que la paz entre irá que
Irán no llegó hasta 1988 Y por supuesto
nadie ganó las fronteras continuaron en
el mismo lugar que estaban antes de la
guerra Eso sí por el camino perdieron la
vida casi un millón de personas y tras
ocho años de destrucción las economías
de ambos países también quedaron
destrozadas sin embargo Cuando acabó
esta guerra Kuwait que era una
petromonarquía aliada de Sadam husein
por aquel entonces empezó a reclamar a
Irak todo el dinero que le había
prestado para combatir a los ayatolas
hablamos Ni más ni menos que de 14.000
millones de dólares Así que la relación
entre ambos países comenzó a torcerse
hasta el punto de que Irak acusó a
Kuwait de robar su petróleo mediante el
uso de técnicas avanzadas en Campos
fronterizos era una acusación sin
fundamento pero el régimen de Sadam
Estaba preparando el terreno para
invadir Kuwait algo que ocurrió en
agosto de 1990 provocando un rechazo
unánime de la comunidad internacional
durante cinco meses la diplomacia
intentó que Sadam hussein retirara sus
tropas de el consejo de seguridad de la
ONU aprobó cinco resoluciones en este
sentido y finalmente el 16 de enero de
1991 una coalición internacional de 34
países encabezada por Estados Unidos y
bajo mandato de la propia ONU inició una
campaña militar para obligar al ejército
Invasor a replegarse de Kuwait la
resolución 660 de la ONU que amparaba
esta operación fue aprobada de forma
unánime
y así es como comenzó la guerra del
Golfo la primera de toda la historia en
ser televisada en directo la operación
Tormenta del desierto duró seis semanas
y fue todo un éxito vamos fue tan
exitosa que incluso Estados Unidos
hubiera podido derrocar fácilmente Adam
hussein es más el general Norman
schwarkov que estaba al frente de la
operación militar asegura que le llegó a
pedir al presidente Bush padre una
semana más para acabar con Sadam pero la
Casa Blanca no quiso en una entrevista
para Frontline de la cadena pbs su arco
ofrece detalles de Por qué no derrocaron
a Sadam husein en 1991 atentos me
hubiera encantado haber ido a Bagdad y
capturar pero esta no fue una decisión
emocional fue una decisión estratégica y
estratégicamente fuimos lo
suficientemente inteligentes como para
ganar la guerra y ganar la paz sí Sadam
fue la reemplazado mañana probablemente
sería reemplazado por alguien que está
malo o peor que él general Norman sward
posiblemente los más jóvenes estaréis
pensando Vale pues bien me ha quedado
Claro que a finales del siglo pasado
había un señor que se llamaba Sadam
husein y que era el malo de la película
pero qué hizo para convertirse en
semejante Villano incluso muchos os
preguntaréis pero a ver Fonseca si era
tan malo porque no lo derrocaron en 1991
Pues bien la historia de San José
arranca en los años 60 en una época de
golpes de estado en Irak donde la
posición de San husein mejora tanto que
pasa del exilio a la vicepresidencia de
la República gracias al liderazgo en el
partido Baz árabe socialista
el socialismo árabe fue una corriente
ideológica muy popular A mediados del
siglo XX supone una mezcla de tres
elementos clave socialismo con una
economía centralizada dirigida por el
estado laicismo ya que están en contra
de poner el liderazgo religioso por
encima del político y militarismo con un
papel destacado de las fuerzas armadas
en la organización del estado
Pues bien el socialismo árabe fue
evolucionando comenzó siendo para la
vista con el objetivo de unir a todos
los árabes en una sola patria ya que
consideraban las fronteras existentes
como artificiales Pero al final los
enfrentamientos entre los dirigentes
bacistas de los diferentes países
desembocó en la aparición de ramas
nacionalistas del partido Baz y así es
como sadampusaim pudo rechazar cualquier
injerencia y en 1979 se convirtió
formalmente en el presidente de Irak y
como os podéis imaginar Sadam dictador
que gobernó el país con mano de hierro
rodeándose de una élite que como él era
musulmanese sunitas los musulmanes
sunitas eran una minoría que apenas
constituye una quinta parte de la
población iraquí luego Sadam se dedicó a
invertir el dinero que generaba el
petróleo en el ejército lo convirtió en
el cuarto ejército más grande de todo el
planeta algo que no está nada mal para
un país que entonces apenas tenía 18
millones de habitantes y ya sé lo que
estaréis pensando muchos vale era un
dictador pero un dictador como otro
cualquiera que le hacía tan malvado Pues
es que no solo oprimía a su pueblo es
que les llegó a asesinar con armas
químicas Sí sí habéis escuchado bien
[Aplausos]
[Música]
en los años 80 Salon hussein cometió una
serie de matanzas contra la población
kurda que vivía en el norte del país y
varios países han calificado como un
genocidio la operación anfal que se
saldó con la destrucción de 4.500
poblaciones y el asesinato de alrededor
de 180.000 civiles episodios como la
masacre de alabya ciudad que fue
bombardeada con armas químicas
provocando 5000 muertos en solo una
noche forman parte de la historia más
negra de la humanidad ahora bien tampoco
seamos ingenuos probablemente este no
sea el motivo por el que se actuó con
tanta fuerza contra la invasión de
Kuwait otro buen motivo está en el zumo
de dinosaurio irá a que es un país muy
rico en el mundo árabe productor de
importantes cantidades de petróleo y de
gas y con kubai su poder hubiera sido
excesivo y ojo porque hablamos de una
época donde todavía no había llegado el
fracking el petróleo evidentemente medio
era también imprescindible para los
mismísimos Estados Unidos sin embargo al
mismo tiempo y por ese mismo motivo se
necesitaba que Irak siguiera
bombardeando crudo para mantener
estables los precios en los mercados
internacionales y sabéis Qué es posible
que esto explique en buena medida porque
Estados Unidos no quiso acabar con el
régimen de Sadam sí era un dictador
terrible pero tenía el país controlado y
necesitaba vender petróleo para seguir
financiando el ejército Así que entonces
es como se puso en marcha el juego del
palo y la zanahoria si te pasas de listo
Te damos un toque y amenazamos con
invadirte Pero si te comportas te
dejamos estar porque así Irak permanece
estable sin embargo esta política cambió
en el año 2003 Y diréis por qué
[Música]
no a la guerra
los atentados del 11 se dejaron en shock
a la gran superpotencia norteamericana
Estados Unidos había sido atacado en su
propio territorio por al-qaeda y el
presidente George Bush esta vez el hijo
habían prendido una guerra contra el
terror esto condujo a la invasión de
Afganistán donde el régimen talibán daba
cobijo a Osama Bin Laden el líder de al
qaeda logró escabullirse de las fuerzas
estadounidenses Así que la Casa Blanca
empezó a ver en todas partes enemigos
que pudieran echarle una mano y claro el
historial de San José Inn no ayudaba
claro que el tiempo ha demostrado que
los nexos entre al-qaeda y samán husein
eran falsos pero que ambos odiaran a
Estados Unidos ya era suficiente para la
administración bus de este modo el
gobierno estadounidense logró que el
consejo de seguridad de la ONU aprobara
la resolución 1441 una resolución con la
que la comunidad internacional instaba
Irak a colaborar con los inspectores de
desarme pero Washington quería más
presionaba para que se otorgara un
ultimátum a Sadam hussein sin embargo
mis queridos amigos de visualpolitik
este ultimátum nunca llegó y en marzo de
2003 la Casa Blanca decidió hacer la
guerra por su cuenta hasta el último
momento bus de convencer al mundo entero
del peligro de no actuarlo
[Música]
somebody
efectivamente la razón oficial para
invadir Irak fue que Adam hussein
supuestamente tenía ocultas las famosas
armas de destrucción masiva
había dudas y una parte muy importante
de la comunidad internacional se oponía
a esta intervención pero pese a ello El
Congreso de Estados Unidos autorizó en
octubre de 2002 atacar iraq y la
diplomacia fracasaba de hecho el
presidente Bush contó también con una
amplia apoyo de senadores del partido
demócrata es decir el otro partido de la
republicano por ejemplo el propio Joe
biden es decir el actual presidente de
los Estados Unidos El objetivo es
obligar a destruir sus armas ilegales de
destrucción masiva y sus programas para
desarrollar y producir misiles y más
armas de ese tipo sadames peligroso el
mundo sería un lugar mejor sin él Joe
biden como senador en el año 2002 Sin
embargo a diferencia de la guerra del
Golfo esta vez no hubo una gran
coalición internacional para combatir a
Sadam hussein tan solo Reino Unido envió
un fuerte contingente de tropas mientras
que los gobiernos europeos se dividían
entre los que estaban en contra de la
guerra Como por ejemplo Francia y
Alemania y los que apoyaban la
intervención Como por ejemplo España
Italia y gran parte de Europa del este
El caso es que quizás por Esta división
la invasión causó una gran polémica y se
produjeron multitudinarias por todo el
mundo Nadie entendió por qué había que
invadir Irak y artistas intelectuales
lideraron movimientos populares
internacionales como el famoso no a la
guerra en España o el Note Blood pero
pese a todo esto la invasión fue un gran
éxito a nivel militar
el ejército estadounidense conquistó
Bagdad en tan solo tres semanas y apenas
seis semanas después de que diera
comienza la guerra el presidente George
Bush anunció el final de las grandes
operaciones militares en Irak además lo
hizo bajo un gran cartel que ponía
Misión cumplida algo que fue muy
criticado con el paso del tiempo a la
vista de que aún estaba muy lejos de
pacificar el país además en este
discurso bus se marcó un nuevo objetivo
conseguir un Irak democrático
efectivamente se había conquistado
Bagdad y todo eso había funcionado muy
bien se había derribado la gran estatua
de Sadam husein se había prestado a ese
gran ejército iraquí pero sin embargo
todavía quedaban muchos Cabos sueltos el
más importante es que no se había
pensado El dictador se había tomado su
palacio pero no había ni rastro de él ni
de su dinero ni por supuesto de las
supuestas armas de destrucción masiva
Tuvo que pasar medio año para que
finalmente se encontrara Adam husein
escondido en un agujero en el suelo fue
entregado a las nuevas autoridades
iraquíes y el juez que contra él acabó
de la única manera posible condenado a
morir en la horca recordad que fue
juzgado en Irak no en Estados Unidos y
de hecho se mostró desafiante hasta el
final Mirad lo que hizo cuando se enteró
de su Sentencia
estáis A favor o estáis en contra de la
guerra de Irak hay que reconocer una
cosa fue un gran Éxito para los Estados
Unidos habían reafirmado su poder
indiscutible como la gran potencia
militar del momento habían conseguido
invadir un país Ultra militarizado en
tan solo tres meses y tenían motivos de
sobra para darse por satisfechos pero
claro esto no era más que el comienzo de
ese gran objetivo de hacer un Irak
democrático y ahora es cuando viene el
gran dilema realmente se puede construir
una democracia Pues ahora mismo lo vamos
a ver
[Música]
es posible imponer la democracia
mucha gente considera que Bush era un
iluso porque se pensaba que podía
imponer la democracia en un país por la
vía militar porque claro como Sadam
husein había sometido a Irak con una
dictadura criminal la Casa Blanca se
debió imaginar que en Irak todos estaban
esperando que llegaran los Marines les
salvaran del tirano Y entonces todos
contentos irían a votar el problema El
problema es que para tener una
democracia primero tienes que tener un
estado y en la guerra el estado había
sido destruido ahora bien Vamos a
decirlo claro eso de llegar a un país
devastado y poner una democracia no es
ninguna locura y de hecho ya ha
funcionado ahí tenemos el caso de
Alemania o Japón Incluso en Corea del
Sur de la Segunda Guerra Mundial
salieron años después la democracia
alemana y la japonesa y Estados Unidos
jugó un papel decisivo para que así
fuera y de la guerra de Corea salió
Corea del Sur cierto es que durante las
primeras décadas pasaron digo los
surcoreanos por un sistema autoritario
por una dictadura militar pero con el
apoyo estadounidense terminaron
convirtiéndose en la democracia próspera
Que son hoy en día sin embargo volviendo
a Irak y Afganistán todo parece más
complicado
en 2021 Estados Unidos puso fin a la
guerra de Afganistán y ya visteis el
desastre la democracia afgana sucumbió
ante los talibanes en Irak sin embargo
las cosas han sido diferentes Obama
anunció La retirada total de las tropas
en 2011 pero los enemigos de la joven
democracia aquí eran de tal calado que
exigieron el regreso del Tío Sam apenas
tres años después Estados Unidos
despliega nueva fuerza en Irak para
impulsar la lucha contra el estado
islámico está claro que Estados Unidos
cometió muchos errores en Irak apostó
por líderes que promovían las divisiones
sectarias y étnicas como forma de ganar
apoyos políticos que gobernaban para los
suyos antes que servir a los intereses
nacionales y así era muy difícil
construir un nuevo estado para todos los
iraquíes otro error fue disolver el
ejército esta decisión favoreció que las
antiguas tropas de Sadam nutrieron una
insurgencia atomizada en múltiples
grupos armados decididos a luchar contra
El Invasor una insurgencia tan difícil
de combatir como de derrotar ahora bien
la realidad es que en Irak sí que se han
producido cambios de calado desde el año
2005 han celebrado elecciones libres y
dentro de la debilidad de las jóvenes
instituciones iraquíes se puede decir
que 20 años después de Sada husein hay
una democracia funcionando en Irak una
democracia donde el poder se transfiere
de forma relativamente pacífica y cada
vez hay mayor seguridad en las calles es
más incluso la producción de petróleo
también nos da una buena pista de cómo
ha ido evolucionando un Irak Y
actualmente es el segundo mayor
productor de la upep con más de 4
millones de barriles diarios sin embargo
un problema de la Democracia era aquí
que también se produjo en Afganistán es
la corrupción Nacho vidaliana
de los saqueos en las calles se ha
pasado a saquear el erario público de
una forma que ríete tú del ak-47 bañado
en oro de saddam pero de los problemas
del Irak actual hablaremos en un próximo
vídeo la reflexión final es que George
Bush lo hizo Irak se transformó en una
democracia Eso sí a un precio
prohibitivo muchas vidas se quedaron por
el camino pero también tuvo que poner
mucho Money porque Estados Unidos se
gastó un auténtico pastizal en esta
guerra 800.000 millones de dólares según
las estimaciones más prudentes y
billones billones Castellanos de dólares
según las más generosas y todo para que
en contra de lo que muchos pensaran en
Bagdad terminará gobernando lo más
alejado a lo que podríamos considerar
como un títere de Washington
en una democracia gobiernan las mayorías
y en Irak la mayoría de la población es
chiírita por tanto hoy en día están
gobernando en Irak las facciones chitas
que más apoyo han recibido de Irán la
gran potencia del isla y hoy por hoy uno
de los mayores archienemigos de
Washington el mayor error de Invasión
fue no tener un plan para el futuro
después de la guerra
porque sí Irak es una democracia pero
ahora mismo es una democracia bajo la
influencia de la República islámica de
Irán el archienemigo de los Estados
Unidos y la gran triunfadora tras la
guerra la mayor demostración de que la
estrategia estadounidense no ha sido
precisamente brillante pero ahora el
turno es para vosotros 20 años después
de la guerra consideráis que fue un
acierto invadir Irak y volviendo a las
palabras de bus valió la pena el
esfuerzo para transformar Irak en una
democracia podéis dejarnos vuestra
respuesta en los comentarios y como
siempre no olvidéis Que aquí en
visualpolitik sacamos vídeos nuevos
Todas las semanas así que suscribíos
este canal y dadle a la campanita para
no perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones si os ha gustado este
vídeo dadle a like y nos vemos en el
próximo un saludo y Hasta pronto
[Música]